hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in round
five of our coverage of the 2016 tata
steel tournament our compares today why
it's gonna be played by the hometown
hero Dutch Grand Master Luca and Wei Lee
he's played this tournament almost every
year for the past 25 years he's missed
one year he did have a run of 19
consecutive years
he is the 126th ranked player in the
world so as far as all the competitors
he's definitely kind of the the last
place but still extremely strong
grandmaster won the Dutch national
championship six years in a row in the
early 2000s so the hometown favorite but
he does have his work cut out for him
because he's playing the number one
ranked player in the world the world
champion Magnus Carlsen is sitting
across from him Magnus Carlsen is tied
every round so far so although Magnus is
playing the black pieces he's definitely
gonna be looking for a win in this
particular game so we're gonna get
started pawn here to d4 I'm Knight f6
pawn enter to c4 pawn g6 Knight c3 and
then pawn to d5 so getting into the
grünfeld of hit opening there's a few
ways that white can really attack this
we have kind of the main line which is
the exchange variation so pawn takes on
d5 Knight captures pawn up here to e4
Knight captures here and c3 pawn
recaptures and then white kind of has
this solid base in the center of the
board and black kind of allows this you
know kind of weakening this pawn
structure here over on the Queen side
for white so this is kind of the main
line that you'll see other variations
that's very popular for white would be
to play Knight to f3 Bishop here to g7
and then White has lots of different
options you might see Bishop here to g5
very popular you have Queen here to b3
very popular and then just pawn taking
here on d5 similar to the exchange
variation but Luke decides to go ahead
and go a completely different route and
he goes for Bishop to f4 now this is
still a very solid opening for white
always getting the dark square Bishop
involvement into the game before the
pawn kind of solidifies the pawn chain
here at e3 is always strong I usually
like to get my deck or Bishop involved
into the game
early as well [ __ ] period of g7 fin
cutting on the King side and then pawn
here to e3 and magnus carlsen has a few
different options that he can employ he
decides to go for the very uncommon
Grunfeld gambit and that is to play
castle on the kingside it's again
because white could go ahead and accept
the game at this pawn here after the
pawn takes we could see the knight take
the knight recaptured after the Queen
takes now the bishops gonna come here to
a c7 and now this is a gambit because
black is giving up that material in the
center of the board for a very strong
attack that he's going to be getting his
knight outside here maybe Knight here to
a6 but he has his dark square Bishop
involvement of the game his Queens in
the center of the board his life square
bishop involved over here on white side
he's not going to cast on the Queen side
we can already see that there's just not
enough protection and he's kind of a few
moves away he's gonna have to give the
Stars for a bishop back then he's gonna
have to move a couple pieces to castle
on the Kings side so with that magnus
carlsen would have ample time to go
ahead and get back in the game although
he gave up that material so white does
have that option in the game though
decides to play rook here to see one now
wicked or c1 Queen here to b3 kind of
the two ways to semi decline the gambit
rook here to see one you can still
depending on how black moves continue
with the game it later on and magnus
carlsen actually allows him to do that
so he plays bishop here to e6 he wants
to kind of play this before he plays
pawn here to e6 because then you can get
your LightSquared bishop in this
particular variation it just kind of
gets blocked in Magnus Carlsen does not
want to do that so he first plays a
bishop here to e6 and so now we start to
see some exchange on board pawn takes on
d5 the Knight takes Knight recaptures
Bishop takes and now the bishop comes up
here to a c7 and this Bishop is now
protected by the realcare on c1 which we
saw a little bit early now it would be a
lot worse if the rook were to take here
on c7
because now the pawn could come out down
here to e5 this Bishop was protecting
the rook but now this is kind of
stopping it right here so after the pawn
takes yarn
five than just queen takes on c7 this is
very bad now the Queen could come up
here take the bishop Queen down here to
see one Queen comes back and then the
Queen takes this material right here
all in all whites Queen sides completely
decimated there's no protection here on
the King side it's gonna be Wofford
Castle definitely going to be a much
better game with Queen and the two rooks
compared to white set up on the board so
we'll come back after the bishop takes
here on c7 we're gonna see Queen here to
d7 and the bishop comes back here to g3
now well I did have the option since
this pawn is being attacked right now on
a2 by the bishop here on d5 he could try
to hold on to that material so it could
play pawn here to b3 and then we see the
rook over here to c8 Bishop back here to
g3
Knight here to c6 white is up and
material by a pawn but the kind of looks
at he says okay magnet rosen has a
pretty scary board he has all of his
pieces developed his King side safety
over here this is gonna be definitely
worth it for Magnus Carlsen with all the
tempo he's kind of got from this on the
flip side white doesn't have any of his
King side material developed and his
Queen side is very very exposed so he
decided to instead to play bishop back
here to g3 and then the bishop takes
here on a2 now White has more options
now he could try to play pawn here to b3
this is not quite the poisoned pawn so
the bishop can't take care on b3 that
would be silly because the Queen could
take it but now the Queen can come here
to d5 if the rook were to come up here
to c5 we could you see an exchange on
board but after the bishop takes we kind
of see the same scenario though the
Queen side is completely decimated Black
has really nice King safety over here he
can easily get his pieces developed into
the game night here to c6
give us rooks connected over here it's
gonna be a few moves before Y can really
do anything with his pieces over here so
he decides not to go and play that pond
near to b3 the set decides to play
Knight here to e2 recognizing the needs
to start getting some of his King pieces
involved King side pieces involved into
the game so we see Bishop come back here
to a d5 Knight here to c3
and then Bishop here to c6 this is a
pretty valuable square for magnus
carlsen you know Luke really wants to
play his Bishop coming out here getting
involved into the game maybe castle on
the Kings side get some safety and
really start to attack his opponents but
he can't do that with the bishop here
because as soon as he moves it he's just
gonna lose his pawn right here so that's
not good really good square for a magnus
carlsen white now goes for something I
was not expecting at all and he plays
pawn here to h4 so really starting to
attack this feeling kind of pawn chain
over here on the kingside recovery here
to d8 centralizing that rook Queen here
to a b3 Queen here to f5 attacking the
square here on f2 and then push up this
pawn to h5 I would do C pawn here to e6
just solidifying the center of the board
a little bit's pawn takes pawn take so
why it's kind of looking for this rook
to kind of attack this h-file maybe get
some support later on by a queen or a
different rook but right now that works
kind of hanging out by himself here on
h1 now the Queen's gonna come back here
to d1 so just decide to kind of move
back and forth right now a knight here
to d7 getting ready to position to come
over here to the Kings side a bishop
here to d3 attacking the Queen the Queen
is forced to move so the Queen comes
over here to a5 pinning down the knight
to the king now White has a few options
here he can go ahead and castle on the
Kings side that's gonna be my preferred
option this fits your case or you could
just play King here to f1 he decides to
go and play King to f1 can't castle
anymore not the worst thing in the world
but I would have preferred castling
connecting my rooks back here and then
you can get your queen involved however
you want to but he's kind of still
holding out hope that you can have his
rook here on h1 maybes have some big
attack over here on the Kings side so
the knight here to f6 attacking that the
King side and then Bishop here to e5
Magnus brings his rook over here to c8
just trying to connect them control more
the board wasn't doing a ton over there
on a 8
Queen here to d2 if he ever allows
himself to play pawn here to e4 this
would kind of open himself up to get his
queen involved to h6 depending on where
this bishop lies on a g7 a knight here
to a g4 just starting to attack both the
bishop here in e5 and the king side over
here we do see an exchange on board this
is kind of playing into what Luke wants
to do he wants to get the King here so
that he can maybe have a surprise attack
on h6 if he ever has a discovered attack
after pawn here to e4 and I would see
paneer to f3 forcing the knight back and
then we see kind of crazy Magnus Carlsen
he plays Queen here to g5 and this this
is kind of borderline it's half crazy
it's half genius you're not really sure
even if you study this for a long time I
stared it for about 10 minutes just to
figure out how crazy it is not it's half
crazy half genius but after rook here to
our Queen here to g5 we see the pawn
take here on g4 we're gonna come down
here to d4 and as you can see the pawn
can't take here because the Queen is
just going to fall so the King comes
over here to II 1 and then we see Queen
to e5 same thing pinning down this pawn
the pawn can't take right here and then
I down here to e2 so now the pawn can
take if he wants to so we say the rook
take over here on a g4 so right away
Black has kind of given up a minor piece
for two pawns with a very very strong
attack on the board now white plays pawn
here to e4 kind of setting up what we've
been hoping to see getting ready for the
Queen to come here to h6 so Magnus
Carlsen kinda has two options you can
play pawn here to g5 and kind of stop
that attack you could also just play
rook here to g5 and that also kind of
stops it he makes a huge blunder though
he plays rook here - G - very very bad
not sure if he just didn't see Queen
here to h6 but we quickly see Queen here
to h6 check and then King here to f6 and
then we kind of expect to see the Queen
come back here
to h4 we don't see this in the game this
is definitely the much better choice on
the board as far as what the king could
do were mostly gonna just see the pawn
come here to g5 if the Queen were to
come here to g5 that's just really bad
it gets crazy after pawn here to e5
that's all sorts of problems but after
pawn here to g5 then the Queen here to
h3 this rook is going to fall why it's
gonna end up being up material on the
board even if we see you know the rook
take here the bishop is just going to
take that's fine lots of variations that
this can go into even if we see the rook
come over here to d8 attacking this
bishop we could see the Queen take the
rook down coming down here rook up here
to c4 kind of holding down this material
right here with both the rook and the
Queen right here but if you kind of look
at material on board two rooks going
into the in game this is going to be a
good easy game for white Magnus Carlsen
just just didn't see it at all but
instead of playing that if we come back
here instead of playing the Queen down
here to h3 we see the rook or Queen to
h4 first we see rook here to c3 doesn't
add a ton of value on board really
allows Magnus Carlsen to get back in the
game and now Magnus Carlsen plays rook
here to d8 so this is completely fine
for Magnus Carlsen now and so white kind
of deviates from the plane and now plays
Queen here to h3 now the Queen's gonna
come over here to g5 now rook to f1 we
see the queen or king come back here to
g7 Queen here to f3
just trying to solidify a little bit
rook down here to d7 protecting this
pawn right here on f7 since both the
Queen and the rook on f1 are kind of
attacking this so rook up here to f2
attacking the rook they're going to come
up here to g4 and then Knight to f4 now
I think it's worth I was really hoping
that we would see Knight here to d4 this
could have gone down
is one of the most just epic things of
all time because it's a true gambit and
magnus carlsen seems to have made some
mistakes so far in this game even in the
tournament so far he's kind of alluded
to it hasn't been his best tournament so
far
so after Knight to d4 we could have
definitely seen although it's it's a low
possibility it definitely could have
happened and it would have been awesome
that would have been table flipping all
over the place but after a rook takes
here on d4 we could see Queen takes on
f7 and this is a forced mate King here
to h6 Queen up here
Queen to H a queen can be involved now
get the rook involved Bishop gets
involved the King comes here and then
boom we have checkmate there's no way to
really stop that I think even if magnus
carlsen doesn't fall for that I still
think it's fine
Knight to d4 just seems way cooler my
opinion then Knight to d4 which is
completely playing defense is just not
doing anything cool at all but after
Knight here to f4 we see the Queen come
to h4 and then a really really terrible
move we see Bishop to e2 just really
deteriorates the position that he had
potentially trying Knight to g2 kind of
stopping this thread of the knight
coming down here to g1 that's really
what he needed to do on the board he
played Bishop to e2 now rook here to g1
bishops kind of forced to stop that King
here to g8
qinger to g8 I met you know Magnus
Carlsen he didn't have to play this this
is not providing any value at all he
could have easily just played pawn here
to e5 kind of forcing the knight to move
or the rook to move after taking you
know this is all gonna be fine there's
no reason to really play you know kind
of what he did even after your pawn to
e5 you can see Knight to d5 you can see
the pawn now come here this pawns of
protecting the night all of a sudden
it's kind of blowing this up it's gonna
be a very very good game for Magnus
Carlsen here but he decides to play King
back here to g8 just kind of a slower
grind and now Knight here to e2 also a
very very terrible move he's
probably should have just tried Knights
of G to kind of block off some of the
symmetry that he has in his attack but
after night here - E - then the rook
takes King recaptures now that rook down
here to d1 I'm not I'm just not sure
that he saw this rook coming down here
to d1 except her King here - G - Bishop
takes here on e4 and this is kind of
good game there's no way to kind of stop
this the queen is going to fall so you
know Luke was forced to resign in this
situation a lot of mistakes from both
sides you know Magnus Carlsen for a
second there it really looked like he
was going to give this thing away after
the Queen came up here to h6 Luke for
some reason decided to play his rook to
c3 which did not provide a lot of value
and then continued to make a few
mistakes and didn't try to make the hero
play with the knight - a d4 which would
have been amazing it would have worked
but all in all Magnus Carlsen finally
got a win so he is kind of moving
towards the top of the leaderboard we've
had a lot of drawls in this tournament
so anyone you can get is kind of moving
you up in a little leaderboard so we
still have a ton of chess to play it's
one of the longer tournaments with 14
competitors so we'll see if Magnus
Carlsen can continue this trend always
good to get a win with the black pieces
but hopefully you guys are enjoying the
tournament so far had coverage in every
round and will continue to do so
throughout but thanks for watching and
I'll see you guys in the next video